you mostly really bleed for someone else
to get up and go and shave and put on
heels and Chucky dick away and put on
makeup and go to a club for four hours
it's just what I do
my mum kind of came around to me being
gay quite quickly and stuff she said as
long as you're not a drag queen I'm
happy my close-knit group of friends
just call me penny friends from the
early days call me tration my normal
friends just called me Daniel or if I'm
in trouble from my mom it's dead so I
used to watch Buffy the Vampire Slayer a
lot and I love the character Cordelia it
was played by charisma carpenter and so
I took her name because she was really
beautiful and I thought that I was
really beautiful yeah I'm just such a
girl wanted to be was a flight attendant
a flat urchin or an actor and I got to
tour for both well maybe it wasn't too
tall to be an extra I just had no talent
two or three months after I came out my
mum walked down to me instead I don't
wake up every morning and think about
Robert which is my younger brother is
straight so I guess I won't wake up
every morning and think that Daniels gay
I went and saw the movie Priscilla and I
was like oh there's something that
combines smoke machines weeds
microphones and everything was just like
this is what I was meant to do
I'm socially awkward I enjoy spending a
lot of time on my own so I think you've
learned to become a good actor
27:27 dresses is a awful movie Nathan is
usually quite shy penny can walk into a
room and own the room and get invited to
parties and staying up for days on in
drag is fun you know it's an
exaggeration of life well this is my
drag cage for one of a better word where
I keep my costumes my wigs my makeup
jewelry and bag the shoes the four-inch
heel with a two inch platform at the
front I use a heavy cover foundation to
get rid of my 5 o'clock shadow which is
usually there from 10 o'clock
breastplates the boys like those ones
when I love color like very 80s it's the
bigger the eyelashes the easier it is to
cover mistakes and glitter is your best
friend as well
most people are seeing me from five to
ten meters away and that's really the
best marriage for drag to be admirer
every now and then is just like one
super long one it's like growing
overnight
[Music]
so tonight we going to a bar called
Henry Lee's so this would normally have
been two hours of absolute binge
drinking but now I'm a grown-up and I
Drive to work 55 my say comes alive
before I put up these three layers of
time tied stocking hands and makes me so
upset but we didn't have the Internet if
you wanted to learn makeup how to tie
your shoes properly how to talk how to
pad you just worked it out yourself
we used to keep that a secret because
the more people that knew the more jobs
that you could have stolen off of you
and so when someone younger probably
pretty out comes along it's always other
big daunting for for some of the
questions if you come stepping on my
toes or you come knocking on a club's
door that I work at and try and undercut
me out there I've posted the deep
rewards three times until I did it one
year and I got far too drunk I haven't
done it against oh actually I did do it
once since then and I got pretty drunk
again so I don't think I'll do it again
the sofa pay is open mic night for young
drag queens they battle it out for a
cash prize do you think I'm sexy they
know that the drunker we are the more
while that we are more fun people going
to have the more money people are gonna
spend got a 500-700 cash jackpot so
someone will walk home with a big prize
that's more than any Westpac employee
got as their Christmas bonus this year a
bond a surfer su green the colored card
so-called spawned a surf rescue green
because that is a color of snot dripping
out of our international tourists notes
I created training bingo I wanted to
find another word that was still fun
[ __ ] bingo was naughty at the time it
was no longer acceptable although he
said anything good say that anymore
we became gender bender bingo it's a
more inclusive name it's more
appropriate to use these days it's more
acceptable for the time being quite
often especially I've had a few drinks I
tend to call the numbers the same or I
forget what we're doing yeah I forgot I
forgot to bring bingo kwillet7 if you
know foe bingo which is French for
you either with a vagina of shame or the
titty hat there we're not gender
specific we just lost it a cab when were
in a room together generally what we
talk about is the person we like the
least it reads out in your eye if all
you do is living clubs dress up as
someone else get on stage get treated
like a star you know some friends did it
make it out they weren't able to
differentiate between the fantasy of
drag and the reality of life my
biological dad who I haven't lived with
since I was 8 years old
we don't talk because because I'm gay
and I'm not even sure to be honest that
he knows I'm a famous drag queen if I
walk past him in a street in 4 battlin
that we probably wouldn't recognize me I
don't think people realize the amount of
parents that have come up to us and said
hey I think my son my daughter is gay
and that have been able to have a
one-on-one conversation with someone
that probably understands a little bit
more and that's probably been one of my
proudest achievements we've
gender-bender bingo
you like the lgbtqia+ community have
always we've really looked after each
other you know some of my closest
friends are my drag sisters and some of
my worst enemies and the people I've had
the best arguments with are my drag
sisters
we're a close-knit community we probably
have a lifestyle that very few other
people understand drag to me is about
entertainment and about making people
happy but I'd love to stay out talking
on the streets cuz you know that's not
my best work I gotta get back in there
[Music]